this morning in our ion money series we
were looking at how buying habits can
affect your credit score and your
ability to borrow money a recent
creditcards.com survey found a large
majority of Americans with debt would
not be willing to cut spending on
leisure travel on clothing or on shoes
by 50% CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here with how these
choices can impact your credit if you're
not willing to cut you are going to
spend it your bill will increase that
could hurt your score right and and so
we should just make a distinction
because people get really confused there
is credit report there is a credit score
they're different so we have companies
that compile all of your information
basically do you pay your bills on time
how much credit do you have those kinds
of statistics and the big three are
Equifax Experian and TransUnion they put
all the information together sometimes
they sell it to different vendors but
they usually are putting it towards
someone who's putting together a score
like FICO is really the most famous one
and the more could really hurt you if
it's low well that score is basically
saying to the world you are credit
worthy or not so credit worthy you
should extend credit or not to this
petition you want to buy a car you want
to buy it you want a mortgage for a
house that's course critical yeah it's
not only a car or a house interesting it
can be used for insurance purposes some
employers you use a skinny down credit
reporting in certain states they can use
that so it's important to have good
credit and make sure there's no errors
on those reports often should you check
your credit score well there is a great
website called annual credit score calm
and annual is the good time so you get
it free every year you should check that
because you want to clarify if there are
any areas you want to get them off
remember if your score is artificially
low it's gonna cost more to borrow money
and you know scoring goes from 300 to
850 no one has a 300 by the way but it
really yours right now but it is
important because the lower your score
the more it costs to borrow money what
do you mean by artificially low I mean
what are the causes that would would
drop it down and how do you get it back
up so if you saw an error on
credit report and it might have said
you've got an outstanding credit card
balance of blank let's just call it 3000
4000 5000 dollars and you say wait a
second I paid that off your score could
be down because that error has not been
cleaned up okay so here's a deal 670 is
this magic line below 670 it costs more
to borrow 672 about 740 is considered
good or very good
and Anthony you'll be happy to know I'm
sure you're sporting that more than 800
oh you must be up there is considered
excellent and here's the problem if you
don't have good credit when you need it
it's hard to actually drive that score
do you do to drive the score up the most
important factor is pay your bills on
time and that may seem silly but even if
you could just ought if you're carrying
credit card debt and I don't care why
you got into it but if you have it
automate your bill paying so you can get
that bill paid on time so there are five
different factors paying your bill on
time is the most important how much
credit you have available to you if you
use too much of your available credit
accounts against you and weirdly in some
instances if you close a credit card
account it can sometimes drive down your
score it's very strange so if you want
to get rid of that credit card that's
outstanding just put it in the back of
your drawer don't worry about it don't
go and cancel it quickly Jill how long
typically does it take to bring down a
score on it as most things it goes down
faster than it goes up even people
though who have declared bankruptcy it
can take a lot less time just to get
yourself back on track pay attention to
this again it drives many decisions in
your financial life for the record I'm
in the seventh oh wow thank you can we
sing about that my mother I will all
right with cameras hi Susan
it was a wonderful guest we appreciate
having around every morning thank you
thank you